bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau et premier numéro pour l'année
2015 au sommaire de cette édition notre
rencontre avec un magicien du coeur au
centre hospitalier de versailles il
parcourt les chambres des enfants
malades pour leur redonner le sourire
nous irons ensuite à montigny le
bretonneux le pôle jeunesse de la ville
propose des ateliers ludiques aux jeunes
pour les sensibiliser aux addictions
au sommaire également notre reportage à
la croix rouge lors d'une formation aux
premiers secours
mais tout d'abord le premier sujet au
coeur de l'actualité depuis plusieurs
semaines les médecins généralistes se
font entendre et se bat contre le projet
de loi santé que le gouvernement veut
faire voter au printemps 2015 dans les
yvelines le bras de fer ne faiblit pas
patrick jacques de dixmude pour les
images
grève fermeture des cabinets médicaux ou
encore au refus de la carte vitale les
médecins généralistes se mobilisent
depuis plusieurs semaines l'objet de
leur colère le projet de loi santé que
le gouvernement veut faire voter au
printemps 2015 parmi les mesures
principales qui hérisse l'obligation et
la généralisation du tiers-payant jugé
inapplicable par ce médecin yvelinois il
faut qu'on soit payé d'une part par la
sécurité sociale dont les sites sont
régulièrement en panne l'appareil trois
jours qu'on ne peut pas accéder aussi de
la sécurité sociale donc impossible de
se faire payer évidemment si on était en
tiers payant et surtout par les
mutuelles il y a près de 500 mutuel en
france il faut qu'on recherche à quelle
mutuelle est affilié le patient
rechercher les impayés globalement tous
ceux qui le pratiquent aujourd'hui c'est
à dire les pharmaciens les centres de
santé et certains médecins
par exemple sur l'île de la réunion nous
disent que ça leur revient à peu près à
3 euros 50 par acte le problème c'est
que la généralisation du tiers payant
n'est pas le seul point noir du projet
de loi épinglé par les médecins on est
en train de retirer la médecine aux
médecins ce seront les pharmaciens qui
vaccineront sont les infirmières qui
suivront les patients diabétiques et
c'est même tenez vous bien c'est même
des employés de sécurité sociale qui
iront dans les hôpitaux pour organiser
la sortie des patients hospitalisés
c'est à dire que c'est eux qui
décideront quelle médecins ils doivent
voir combien de fois ils doivent le voir
dans le mois cette mobilisation contre
le projet de loi c'est aussi l'occasion
pour les médecins généralistes d'alerter
l'opinion publique sur leurs conditions
de travail en france métier dévaloriser
charges financières trop lourdes
contraintes administratives les médecins
en ont ras-le-bol résultat la
désertification médicale et les
problèmes de répartition géographique
sont toujours d'actualité sur montigny
on a à partir du 1er avril 2015 et déjà
à partir du 1er janvier 2000 t elle
depuis quatre médecins qui vont s'en
aller dans le seul quartier de la
fonderie à montigny il y pour l'instant
pas d'actualité qu'il soit remplacé en
attendant tous espèrent une refonte du
projet de loi santé avant le printemps
et pour rester sur ce thème à l'hôpital
privé de l'ouest parisien de trappes
l'activité du bloc opératoire a cessé
pendant plusieurs jours ces praticiens
étaient en grève pour s'opposer au
projet de loi santé du gouvernement
parmi les mesures qui fâchent la
généralisation du tiers payant et le
retrait des autorisations pour les
hôpitaux privés d'assurer des missions
de service public comme les urgences une
minorité de praticiens en pris en charge
uniquement les urgences dit vital
résultat deux patients opérés en trois
jours contre 90 en temps normal au sein
de l'établissement mais face à
l'attentât qui a frappé la rédaction de
charlie hebdo la grève a été suspendue
pour risques sanitaires les praticiens
sont dans l'inquiétude nous écoutons
l'un d'eux les drapeaux soient produits
rillettes et si les services publics
sont discutés même si nous sommes au
travail de venir à décaler il y aura du
taupe trésor dès
l'application est
dans un contexte aussi grave jean qui
vous attend le concert de professionnels
être préparé à toute éventualité m après
noté de revendications la toujours aussi
important parce que ce complot
international
l'association les magiciens du coeur
compte une vingtaine de bénévoles à
travers des tours de magie dans les
hôpitaux ils tentent de sortir les
enfants malades de leur quotidien de
leur redonner un peu le sourire
reportage au centre hospitalier de
versailles les images sont signés elodie
moines
au service de pédiatrie du centre
hospitalier de versailles de niveau var
déambule dans les couloirs avec tout son
équipement de magie et pousse la porte
de chaque chambre
tu fermes bien pas mal tu donnes ta main
alors je claque dans mes doigts et là tu
sois un petit picotement
bénévoles et président de l'association
les magiciens du coeur il vient ici
toutes les semaines à la rencontre des
enfants malades pour les sortir un peu
de leur quotidien
quand on fait de la magie on arrive à
étonner étonné cents spectateurs et
canton layton il ya plein de résistance
qui tombe et tout de suite on est sur
une relation avec
beaucoup moins de barrières une relation
beaucoup plus vrai minata commence à
bien le connaître et les l'une de ses
premières fans chaque fois que je le
vois et vague j'aime bien ses tours ses
drones et puis aussi l'effort je pense
qu'il devrait noter un spectacle invité
jean
curieuse elle lui a déjà demandé ses
petits secrets mais son succès il
éthique un magicien ça révèle pas ses
secrets
ce magicien au grand coeur vient ici
depuis cinq six ans il est aujourd'hui
reconnu par le personnel soignant de
l'hôpital parfois même complice avec eux
c'est un travail pratiquement dès vibrer
j'ai l'impression d'être intégré dans
l'équipe donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
fait vraiment plaisir
quelques mètres plus loin la petite
roxane fait la rencontre du magicien
pour la première fois je la mets dans ma
main regard je souffre sur ma main
elle a disparu
je me demande bien où elle est cette
fleur personne n'a vu la faire
un peu timide au début elle esquisse
finalement quelques petits sourires
c'est très bien
parce que les journées sont parfois
longues surtout pour les petits comme ça
donc voilà un peu un peu de spectacle de
magie ça fait toujours un bon moment à
passer pour ces petits
je suis un grand magicien
et c'est les coloriages
les magiciens du coeur seront également
dans les hôpitaux de bullion et de
garches et dans quelques instituts
médico éducatifs aux
bravos n'a pas débordé dit non
depuis l'ouverture du pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux il ya quatre ans
des actions de sensibilisation aux
addictions sont mises en place auprès
des jeunes dans les établissements
scolaires objectif libérer la parole et
leur donner un maximum d'informations à
travers des ateliers ludiques williams
elle pour les images
donc à les premières lunettes que je
vais essayer c'est 0,8 gramme d'alcool
par litre de sang
normalement à votre âge est ce que vous
avez déjà essayé de consommer de
l'alcool pas du tout juste une fois de
temps en temps
pas du tout ou juste une gorgée ou deux
avec les parents lors de repas familiaux
la consommation d'alcool est quasi
inexistante chez ces jeunes minimes au
sein de l'établissement giacometti avec
ses lunettes spéciales il adopte la
vision de quelqu'un qui aurait beaucoup
trop lu ça donne envie de vomir parce
qu'on a mal à la tête et
le vertige la sensation d'être
renverser un peu
comme si on allait tomber tout le temps
sensibiliser les jeunes aux addictions
c'est l'objectif du pôle jeunesse de
montigny depuis son ouverture il a
quatre ans le temps des pauses déjeuner
comme ici des ateliers ludiques sont
proposés dans les collèges et les lycées
de la ville en fête une drogue on peut
pas s'en passer on peut devenir accro
c'est pas non plus une obligation mais
on peut devenir accro et ne pas pouvoir
s'en passer et la deuxième chose c'est
que ça modifie notre comportement
l'animatrice tente de libérer la parole
des jeunes de leur donner toutes les
informations pour qu'ils se fassent leur
propre piège mais quand ils grandissent
d'autres facteurs entrent en compte l
influence des autres ça joue beaucoup le
peur de pas être intégré au groupe quand
on va dire non donc du coup ils ont
peut-être tendance à consommer après il
y en a quand même qui car leur propre
opinion et ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très important sont bien ces
forces des caractères comme ça et puis
c'est très bien aussi qu'ils puissent
l'idée dans les interventions c'est
toujours qu'il le dise devant les autres
en fait parce que quand la parole elle
passe par nous c'est une chose mais
quand elles passent par eux c'est encore
mieux
certains en tout cas ont déjà leur
petite idée à la cigarette antilles à
l'alcool peut être je sais pas et c'est
une droit qui commet elle est légale
dans les yvelines la croix rouge propose
des formations aux premiers secours dès
l'âge de 10 ans l'apprentissage de se
termine par la remise d'un certificat
officiel est parfois obligatoire pour
certaines professions reportage dans une
session de formation à l'antenne locale
de chevreuse alors là maintenant vous
avez constaté que les inconscients parce
qu'elle n'a pas répondu à
déjà ce que vous voulez a demandé
maintenant qu'est ce que vous allez
faire je
suis très conscient ça vient d'ordonner
une victime est au sol elle ne respire
pas est inconsciente une situation à
laquelle tout le monde peut être un jour
confronté le temps que les secours
arrivent connaître les gestes qui
sauvent est alors primordial
le temps d'une journée dans les locaux
de la croix-rouge à chevreuse les
apprentis se forme à travers différentes
mises en situation parmi les principaux
gestes à connaître la position latérale
de sécurité
l'afa te laisse les victimes sur le dow
et l'allant va retomber au fond de la
gorge et va empêcher la respiration donc
le simple fait mais les victimes sur le
côté ça va le permettez de vomir s'il a
besoin de vomir et de respirer jusqu'à
ce que le square et prend le relais je
me passe aujourd'hui son diplôme de
premier secours civique de niveau 1
nécessaires pour valider sa formation de
coach sportif à il vérifie déjà qui
conduit à respirer ouvre sa bouche
ou même avec la main c'est là clame à
tous sans le mr chow ok donc là et
compte faire espérer d'autres apprentis
comme andré anna sont juste venus se
former pour se rassurer
c'est de façon volontaire pour porter
les premiers secours parce que je n'en
ai aucune connaissance et qui m'arrivait
certaines choses je ne sais pas quoi
faire je panique à la fin de la journée
tous se verront remettre le certificat
officiel délivré par le ministère de
l'intérieur également valable en europe
pour une durée de cinq ans la formation
d'un coût de 60 euros s'adresse à tout
le monde dès l'âge de 10 ans il ya pas
de limite d'âge après on a eu un
candidat une fois qu'ils avaient 80 deux
ans si ma mémoire est bonne sa femme
était cardiaque et il voulait à tout
prix connaître le fonctionnement d'un
défibrillateur donc il est venu sort
mais j'ai trouvé ça très courageux dans
les yvelines 17 unités locale de la
croix rouge propose cette formation
l'organisme forme environ 15% de la
population française encore loin de leur
objectif de 25%
ce numéro de check up se termine avant
nous quittez vous le savez place au
traditionnel agenda le dimanche 25
janvier l'association adultes au voisin
relais organise son premier salon
bien-être du massage californien aux
huiles essentielles en passant par des
ateliers de réflexologie plantaire il y
en aura pour tous les goûts rendez vous
de 10 heures à 19 heures à la maison des
associations de voisins-le-bretonneux et
du côté de trappes le mardi 27 janvier
une robe contre santé est organisée au
centre socioculturel des merisiers le
docteur jacques ce gala abordera le
thème de l'âge et de la mémoire rendez
vous de 13h30 à 15h30 check up c'est
terminé merci de votre attention je vous
donne rendez-vous dans un mois d'ici là
portez vous bien